قيل لي إنك ستشعر
بشيء غير عادي ، لطالما قلت
لنفسي أنني لا أعتقد أنني
سأشعر بهذه الطريقة ، لكن دعني أخبرك أنه من
المدهش حقًا أن هناك وحدة هنا في
المملكة العربية السعودية ، كل القلوب
الأخوة والأخوات المتصلين
يساعدون بعضهم البعض ، إنه لأمر مدهش حقًا ،
أنا أحبه ، أعتقد أنني أشعر بروحي
وعقلي ، قلبي سوف يتم
تطهيره جميعًا إن شاء الله ،
دعواتنا ستقبل بسم الله ، هذه
ليست المرة الأولى هذه  في المرة الثانية
مع زوجتي للمرة
الأولى وأشعر بأمان شديد وأنا
أقدر ما فعلته الحكومة السعودية
بالفعل ، من الروحي للغاية أن تكون
قريبًا جدًا من المسجد ويمكنك أن
تشعر بكل الأشياء الروحية التي
تسأل عنها عند الذهاب  الى الجنة
دعاء الله لنا وبصحة جيدة
وسعادة لنا ولكل
عائلاتنا بلادنا
هذا حقيقي جدا.